I wondered if I could start uh with an
eighth child or having died from strep a
suggestions from one of your health
ministers Lord Markham that uh if
there's an outbreak of strep a in a
class then all those kids should get
antibiotics is that something that
you're going to do well this is a tragic
for the parents of those eight children
who've lost their child due to this
bacteria and what the UK health and
Security Agency are doing is they're
working closely with the schools
involved and giving very specific advice
to those schools which may involve use
of penicillin and so on and they'll have
more to say about that and they're
proviving more general advice to parents
which is to look out for the symptoms so
a sore throat fever high temperature and
also a red or raised rash on the skin
are symptoms of this invasive uh Strep A
outbreak
um one of the things that is your
responsibility as a government is to
keep these kids warm at school
apparently the bills for energy have
gone up 300 what are you doing about it
well a number of things the energy
relief scheme of course is helping
schools over this coming winter and
today we've also announcing 500 million
pounds of capital for schools so a
typical Primary School will get 16 000
pounds of a typical Secondary School 42
000 pounds to enable them very rapidly
to put in place energy saving measures
like LED lighting or better lagging of
pipes and better thermostat control to
help them bring down their their energy
costs and of course all this follows a
major two billion pound extra funding
for schools in the Autumn statement both
next year and the year after in addition
to the money that had already been
allocated to school which is a very good
settlement for schools to help them deal
with with these kinds of pressures all
four major teaching units are balancing
their members about possible strike
action is this government losing control
no not not at all like look I understand
the the pressure that teachers and
teaching assistants feel that they are
and they were all under pressure because
of the cost of living and we're trying
to tackle that and that's what the
awesome statement did it brought in a
range of measures uh to help with the
cost of living teachers uh our pay is
determined by an independent pay review
body and and this year for this
September they were awarded a five
percent increase across the board but
for young teachers coming into the
profession the first year is an 8.9 uh
pay uh pay settlement we think that's
true inflation there is that well strike
action there is not the answer to
dealing with these negotiations and
um it the children have already had a
disrupted time during covid and I think
the last thing children need in our
schools is for teachers to take strike
action I would urson to continue talking
continue discussing and of course it's
the independent pay review body that
will determine uh the pay for next year
and and they have for this year it's not
just School also is it I mean we've seen
the rmt again are now saying that
they're going to strike over Christmas
from Christmas Eve to the day after
boxing day um your colleague Mark Harper
hasn't got a grip on this either well
he's urging the parties to get together
he's facilitating those discussions but
look the rmt is a very disappointing
decision they've been offered by the
employers eight percent rise over two
years if you look at the pay settlements
below but if you look at the pay
settlements outside the public sector
they are generally in the four to six
percent pay range we simply cannot
afford to pay the kind of uh pay demands
that the the the units like the rmt are
paying if we gave if the if all the
Union's demands and the public sector
were agreed we'll be paying an extra 28
billion pounds on the payroll is simply
not affordable we have to tackle the
inflationary pressures in our economy
that's what we're seeking to do that's
what the Autumn statement was all about
as well as being as well as introducing
measures to help people with those cost
of living increases we also have to
tackle inflation that's what's causing
households to pay higher bills and these
sorts of paid demands of 19 and so on
are just not affordable in in the public
it's oriented in the private sector we
just may need the unions to work with
our employers and not to hold the
countries around Collective Union action
brings down governments
well we are negotiating with these with
the unions we're talking to the teaching
unions and the leadership unions and the
mark Harper is facilitating those
discussions
well you know I think the public will
not smile upon the rnt if they start
disrupting train travel in the run-up to
Christmas is a very cold time of year as
we know from the from the news about the
today's temperatures but to do so in the
run-up to Christmas I think is
unacceptable and you cannot hold you
cannot have negotiations overpay uh
while holding the country to to Ransom
we do understand the pressures that the
cost of living pressures that people are
facing and that's what we sought to help
deal with in the Autumn statement that
we had a few weeks ago okay talk to me
about the u-turn on housing your 2019
Manifesto pledged to build 300 000 new
homes a year why is the prime minister
now changing his tune and we are
committed to that we want young people
and not so young people to be able to
get on the housing that the conservative
party it's in our DNA for young people
for people to have uh their own home to
the property owning a democracy is part
of what we stand for and we are
committed to that it's not a heating you
need to you need to work with
parliamentarians they represent people
they uh and their communities we want
there to be Community consent to
building more houses that's how you
deliver these targets of hundreds of
thousands of new homes every year to
make sure that when you make decisions
about warehouses are going to be built
uh that's not a Utah no it's it's
working with parliamentarians is this a
U-turn is this a U-turn
um it looks as though the prime minister
is going to say that onshore wind farms
can go ahead this is all part of the
normal process of taking a bill through
Parliament MPS representative
that he was definitely not in favor of
it and now we're changing his mind was
three months the emphasis is on offshore
wind we are one of the world's leading
suppliers of offshore wind something
like 40 of our energy now comes from
clean renewable sources 99 of solar
power told me in August that they would
he would definitely not be in favor of
onshore wind and uh as I said our
emphasis is still on offshore wind but
when you take legislation through
Parliament you have to uh you have to
discussion you look you use the phrase
you turn I use the phrase parliamentary
democracy this is the normal process of
getting the legislation through parties
at the time you listen to members of
parm you talk to members of parliament
as you take measures through why didn't
you say that the emphasis is still on
offshore wind as a source of of our wind
it's creating hundreds of thousands of
jobs it's as I said 40 of our power now
comes from why didn't he say it's a
parliamentary process what he said was
no I am against onshore wind what he's
said in the summer what he's saying now
is that the emphasis must be on offshore
wind and and that is still a position of
the government but of course we'll
continue to talk to members of
parliament as we take this legislation
through Parliament and that is how our
system has always worked and it should
always work well I'll have to let my
viewers decide if it's a U-turn or not
final thought before I let you go
Michelle men's office saying that she's
going to take a legal action about some
of the claims being made about her
company or was it her company certainly
she made it appeared a lot of money out
of Med Pro
29 million pounds apparently out of a
203 million pound contract that's what
the allegation is
um these VIP Lanes
not going to be great either when we
start looking at it well the issue of
banishment that's a is under
investigation so it wouldn't be right
for me to talk about that but what I
would say is if you think back to the
beginning of this covered crisis back in
February March 2020 the government the
country desperately needed PPE in our
hospitals and so that's what these
issues like the VIP Lane was all about
is about making sure that those people
that could change the manufacturing
processes to produce
PPE uh but that was the emphasis of the
government saving lives getting that PP
into Hospital five billion pieces of PPE
were produced as a consequence and that
did save hundreds of thousands of lives